[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau catane et
d'interdire faut-il rendre la
vaccination contrôle qu'ovide
obligatoire telle est la question que se
pose le gouvernement et les médias
depuis que l'on sait que le variant
delta va devenir majoritaire dans notre
pays alors obligatoire pour les
soignants obligatoire pour les employés
des ehpad en obligatoire peut-être pour
tous ceux qui sont en contact avec du
public et peut-être même pour toute la
population alors dans cette émission on
va poser la question autrement au lieu
de faut-il on va se demander peut-on
rendre le vaccin contre le coc vide
obligatoire d'une question de santé
publique on va faire un débat de
philosophie morale et politique avec
francis wolff
vous êtes philosophe professeur émérite
à l'école normale supérieure vous êtes
l'auteur de nombreux livres vous étiez
venu dans cette émission pour la
réédition de dire le monde en poche il y
a un an et pour le sujet qui nous
concerne aujourd'hui je renverrai les
téléspectateurs vers votre plaidoyer
pour universel qui est paru chez fayard
la question vous abordez rendre le
vaccin obligatoire est ce que c'est une
question qui vous paraît facile ou
simple à trancher
non je pense que c'est une question
difficile à trancher
étant donné que les arguments pour et
contre
dans un premier temps s'équilibre et
après faut se déterminer et je pense que
d'ailleurs je n'ai pas toujours eu la
même position et peut-être que je
n'aurais pas toujours françois saint
pierre vous êtes avocat pénaliste vous
êtes l'auteur de deux livres
remarquables sur la liberté l'état de
droit pour lesquelles je vous ai reçus
dans interdit d'interdire le premier
c'est le droit contre les démons de la
politique parue en 2019
le second c'est un pays qui voudraient
rester libre chronique d'une
accoutumance sécuritaire en 2021 les
deux sont édités par odile jacob même
question est ce que c'est une question
qui vous paraît simple ou facile à
trancher
je crois que c'est vraiment l'une des
questions les plus complexes qui se pose
actuellement est notamment au
gouvernement au parlement
l'état va devoir prendre position et il
est soumis à ce que l'on peut appeler
une injonction paradoxale dans les
arguments de part et d'autre
se contredisent alors ce sera ma
première question d'ailleurs ce problème
peut-il être simplement décrétée par le
gouvernement francis wolff le
gouvernement depuis le début de la crise
sanitaire
il n'est pas seul si je puis dire il a
bien entendu des à prendre des décisions
au jour le jour est dans un état
d'incertitude
il a à côté de lui un certain nombre de
deux autorités scientifiques qui
d'ailleurs ne sont pas toujours d'accord
et qui d'ailleurs et dont les opinions
évoluent au fur et à mesure que les
connaissances s'accroissent
s'approfondissent hippie là d'un autre
côté ce qu'on lui dit de d'une opinion
publique qui est les volatiles qui elle
peut changer d'avis qui d'ailleurs
semble-t-il est en train de changer
d'avis sur cette question donc le
gouvernement celui-ci est tout autre
gouvernement démocratique est en ce
moment lui aussi soumis à des
injonctions contradictoires
alors bien entendu
là dessus il y a des avis qu'on peut
avoir
philosophiquement médicalement
juridiquement politiquement il ya aussi
les calculs à court moyen et long terme
des effets qu'une telle décision
pourrait avoir sur la popularité du
gouvernement ou de l'opposition bref
dans cette dans cette configuration
personne ne dit qu'elle est
véritablement son opinion chacun mesure
quel peut être l'effet de cette mesure
sur l'opinion qu'on va avoir de lui donc
tout cela est évidemment plus que
complexe c'est un écheveau de qui met en
jeu un certain nombre de principes
fondamentaux de notre démocratie de
notre état de droit et pour lequel sans
doute mon interlocuteur sera plus
compétents françois saint pierre est ce
que c'est au gouvernement et à lui seul
de prendre cette décision à votre avis
alors j'ajoute un élément de réflexion à
ce que vient de dire francis wolff le
gouvernement peut-il rendre obligatoire
la vaccination c'est à dire en at-il le
pouvoir le pouvoir légal
la réponse c'est que il doit saisir le
parlement
je pense qu'il n'y a que le parlement
qui est habilité à voter une loi faisant
obligation à une catégorie de personnes
de se faire vacciner alors je dois dire
que cela est déjà le cas puisque je vous
répond de manière technique mais c'est
utile dans le débat le code de la santé
publique prévoit que la vaccination est
obligatoire notamment pour les enfants
pour 11 enfants a eu 11 20 11 maladie
pardon et que les personnes qui
travaillent dans des établissements de
soins et des ehpad doivent également se
faire vacciner pour je crois trois
maladies bien pour lui mais ce ne sont
pas des textes qui sont particulièrement
sanctionnés donc ce qui est important
c'est de voir ici que si le gouvernement
décide de rendre obligatoire la
vaccination contre la coved
à la population son ensemble ou plus
précisément plus vraisemblablement aux
soignants à 100 la fois faire voter une
loi
je vais vous dire que j'ai déjà reçu moi
qui suis avocat je prends la parole de
cette façon-là des emails d'infirmières
et d'infirmiers qui sont extrêmement
inquiets parce que ils prendraient cela
comme une atteinte majeure à leurs
droits
et s'il ne se soumettent pas à cette
injonction
ils perdraient leur travail c'est leur
très grande inquiétude
mais d'un autre côté je dis vie dans la
presse et est très récemment par exemple
en australie
une personne âgée est décédée de l'aco
vide et il a été établi qu'elle avait
été infecté que par par un soignant de
l'ehpad où elle se trouvait et donc la
famille est absolument furieuse contre
cet établissement mais plus encore
contre le gouvernement qui a une
obligation de garantie des patients dans
les établissements de soins faisant
qu'il ne soit pas contaminée par un
soignant c'est pourquoi je parlais
d'injonction paradoxale alors je
voudrais ajouter encore ceci c'est que
les soignants qui refusent de se faire
vacciner
nous avons tous lu dans la presse que il
ya un taux de 50% des médecins qui ne
sont pas vaccinés de je crois 60 ou 70%
des autres soignants qui ne sont pas il
ya quand même un grand nombre de
personnes qui ne sont pas vaccinés ces
personnes ont leurs raisons
c'est pas forcément des complotistes ou
des personnes qui ne résoudrait pas du
tout non il faut les écouter
est ce que ces personnes me demande
c'est si elle aurait un recours contre
une telle obligation
alors je dois quand même dire ici que
réfléchissant aux sujets que vous nous
avez posé
frédéric taddeï que les grands tribunaux
français se sont déjà prononcés sur le
caractère obligatoire des vaccinations
que j'évoquais c'est le conseil
constitutionnel en 2015
le conseil d'état en 2019 est alors très
récemment et ça c'est important ça a été
remarquée
au mois d'avril 2010 21 c'est à dire il
ya cinq mois 4 mois
la cour européenne des droits de l'homme
a rendu une décision qui concerne la
république de tchéquie sur la
vaccination obligatoire des enfants et
la cour européenne des droits de l'homme
a confirmé la législation slovaque mais
pour des motifs qui me semble
intéressant d'évoquer dans notre débat
et je me tais après c'est que elle
considère qu' une telle loi est légitime
en soi elle peut être considérée comme
nécessaire dans une situation donnée
il faut que ce soit approprié les
modalités soit approprié et laisse
surtout aux différents états européens
ce qu'elle appelle une large marge
d'appréciation pour ce faire et donc je
voudrais dire ceci c'est que tout dépend
la manière dont le gouvernement prendra
le sujet et dont le parlement votera une
telle loi si c'est une obligation
générale indistincte à toutes catégories
de population avec une sanction pénale à
la clé je pense que ça n'est pas
possible
en revanche ce qui est vraisemblable
c'est que le parlement dise que pour
être habilités à travailler dans un
établissement de soins
alors il faudra avoir une attestation de
vaccination que vive et une telle
situation une législation je pense en
l'état des choses serait validée par le
conseil constitutionnel le conseil
d'état pour ce qui est des décrets qui
appliqueront cette législation et une
fille née par la cour européenne des
droits de l'homme donc je pense que la
situation est très difficile mais je
devine que la volonté du gouvernement
c'est de de garantir sa responsabilité
surtout d'assumer ses devoirs et c'est
compréhensible mais du coup les
personnes qui seraient très réticente à
cela aurait des recours mais je pense
qu'il serait vain alors restons sur les
soignants pour l'instant effectivement à
la clé c'est l'interdiction
professionnelle y perdraient leur
travail ils seraient licenciés sont ces
mêmes soignants qu'on applaudissait il
ya encore pas très longtemps
des traits qu'à l'époque on envoyait
soigner des balades sans aucune
protection
une époque où il pouvait à la fois et
transmettre la maladie et être
comptables idée ça ne poserait aucun
problème
morales philosophiques de leur queue de
l'est aujourd'hui de leur faire perdre
leur travail alors je suis assez étonné
de la position en particulier qu'a pris
la cgt récemment et auquel peut-être
vous faisiez allusion sur saint-pierre à
l'idée que une obligation pour cette
catégorie professionnelle serait en
quelque sorte stigmatisante vous n'avez
pas employé le bon mais c'est un peu
l'esprit de cette cette idée alors je
suis assez étonné que le fait de soi
protéger d'une maladie contagieuse
serait stigmatisant je ne comprends même
pas l'argument j'ajoute qu'il s'agit
évidemment de les protéger
je comprends très bien que pour telle ou
telle raison qui n'est pas forcément
complotistes en effet on ne souhaite pas
se protéger et dans certains cas peut
être d'une façon rationnelle lorsque ce
qu'on appelle le rapport bénéfice risque
nous semble défavorable mais je ne
comprends pas que l'on puisse laisser ce
qui se passe aujourd'hui dans les
hôpitaux ou dans les ehpad
mais on par aof d'une manière plus
générale dans tous les centres de santé
où c'est la première maladies
nosocomiales c'est à dire vous allez
dans un hôpital pour vous faire soigner
les yeux ou pour soigner un ongle
incarné vous risquez d'attraper le coc
vida dans certains cas d'une façon qui
peut être extrêmement grave c'est quand
même quelque chose d'assez uris ans non
pas qu'on attrape des maladies
nosocomiales mais qu'on attrape une
maladie nosocomiale qui est parfaitement
évitables par la vaccination
parce qu'il est désormais
v j'ai les chiffres de l'institut
pasteur qu'une personne vaccinée à 12
fois moins de chances de transmettre le
virus je ne dis pas de l'attraper
puisque là on est dans des chiffres là
que une personnes non vaccinées
donc on demande simplement ces personnes
d'exercer leur liberté personnelle mais
de ne pas nuire puisque le prince
premier principe médicale puisqu'on en
est à la question des soignants c'est ne
pas nuire c'est le premier grand
principe
or si ces personnes qui sont chargées de
soins transmettent une maladie qui dans
certains cas est plus grave que celle
pour laquelle on vient se soigner c'est
le monde à l'envers je comprends très
bien
j'ai vu les chiffres il semble
qu'aujourd'hui il environ les trois
quarts de la population française soit
en faveur de cette obligation
bien entendu bien entendu
qui dit obligation cela suppose quelque
forme de contrainte voire de menaces de
la sanction est donc et donc de sanction
je suppose qu'il peut y avoir un certain
de sanction graduée mais je suis
persuadé que le simple fait de
l'obligation encouragerait un grand
nombre de ceux qui sont aujourd'hui
réticents à se faire vacciner même sans
la crainte d'une sanction le caractère
simplement obligatoire à lui même des
effets si je puis dire obligeant pour un
esprit si libre soit il françois saint
pierre
alors on nous avons aussi lu dans la
presse qui se passe à l'étranger et
notamment ce qui m'a intéressé c'est que
en italie cette obligation est faite à
défaut de quoi les personnes ne peuvent
plus exercer dans un établissement de
soins et notamment à un ehpad et à lire
la presse
eh bien ça ne fait pas débat et on voit
ici pour faire suite à ce que disait
monsieur wolf à l'instant que les
derniers mois en italie ont été si
terrible que c'est quasiment une
évidence autrement dit une obligation
déontologique dirais-je et votre propos
sur la morale l'éthique professionnelle
des soignants ici et me semble
particulièrement pertinent
maintenant ce que j'observe et encore
une fois dans les quelques contacts que
j'ai pu avoir avec des soignants c'est
que il ya une crainte notamment chez les
plus jeunes
c'est à dire que il y à une inquiétude
sur les préjudices à long terme de ces
vaccins qui sont d'un nouveau genre
alors je suis absolument pas technicien
spécialiste du vaccin mais je pense
qu'il est important d'écouter avec
attention les personnes qui s'opposent à
la vaccination obligatoire et notamment
les soignants puisque ce seront les
premiers visés parce que ils ont leur
dignité
il exerce un métier et les mettre en
situation de choisir entre se faire
vacciner ou
ne plus exercer ce métier je trouve que
c'est une grande pression
une atteinte bien sûr à leurs droits
alors comment raisonne les tribunaux
dans ce cas de figure c'est ce que
j'évoquais tout à l'heure c'est une
question de proportionnalité est ce que
l'intérêt en jeu est supérieur et
justifie une telle une telle injonction
je crois que il est important d'aborder
aussi le sujet de manière très
pragmatique
j'évoquais quelques pourcentages
approximatif
cela concerne combien de personnes n'y
at il pas un travail de conviction de
pédagogie à accomplir
le processus est assez lent et à cet
égard je pense que le premier ministre
est prudent il prend des avis ah
j'allais dire à droite et à gauche mais
à tous égards ce qui lui laisse du temps
et ce qui je pense dans les
établissements de soins permet aussi une
concertation la meilleure solution
serait évidemment que les uns et les
autres soit incitée parce que je
voudrais ajouter deux observations bon
imaginons que cette loi soit votée et
que par conséquent les soignants est à
choisir combien de personnes seraient
impactés et risquerait de perdre leur
emploi
c'est une première question d'une autre
d'un autre côté
or et on le personnel disponible pour
remplacer les personnels défaillant
réticents c'est une vraie question
d'organisation et c'est la raison pour
laquelle prenez par exemple le conseil
d'état lorsqu'il analyse la viabilité
d'un texte de loi à voter
il fait une étude d'impact et je trouve
qu'aujourd'hui on manque d'éléments
d'information très concret on peut avoir
une analyse déontologique juridique mais
concrètement dans les hôpitaux
quel est l'impact c'est une question et
je voudrais aussi ajouter une autre
remarque socialement collectivement vous
évoquez la cgt qui a pris position
les syndicats vont ils réagir
nous sommes dans une situation où la
population dans son ensemble nous tous
sommes allés nerfs à fleur de peau après
les mois qui se sont passées on peut
imaginer que de manière très inattendue
impromptue une forte réaction sociale se
fasse jour
en réponse à une contrainte
supplémentaire de la part de l'état de
cette nature là je n'en sais rien et je
ne le souhaite pas ne nous méprenons pas
dessus souhaite pas être de mauvaise
augure mais je serai au gouvernement je
serai hypersensibles à la conséquence
sociale la réaction sociale d'une telle
contrainte supplémentaire
vous ne pensez aussi francis wolff c'est
vrai qu'on a subi beaucoup de
contraintes
il ya eu d'ailleurs de plus en plus de
résistances à ces contraintes
successives notamment qu d'ailleurs
quand on est on ne subissait pas tous
les mêmes
on a bien vu que le premier confinement
c'est mieux a été mieux supporter parce
que tout le monde qu'un peu il est
astreint que le que les suivants oui
j'ai la pression quand même qu'il est
extrêmement difficile de mesurer à
l'avance les effets d'un pack dont vous
parliez lorsqu'il a comme un art ce
qu'on a commencé à parler de vaccination
on avait en france des taux à uhry sand
anti-vaccins ces taux n'ont pas arrêté
de descendre depuis de telle sorte que
maintenant une majorité assez écrasante
de français sont pour la vaccination ne
signifie pas qu'ils se font vacciner
donc c'est extrêmement difficile de
prévoir
depuis il yal'expérience les gens
s'aperçoivent qu'au tour de deux les
gens sont vaccinés et que ça n'a pas eu
de conséquences catastrophiques
de plus en plus de gens aussi
connaissent des gens qui ont eu comme
idée parfois dans des états graves mais
je voudrais me placer un autre niveau
vous avez une fixité le cas de l'italie
et je crois que la question que nous
nous posons là ce soir est un tout petit
peu hors sujet par rapport aux problèmes
même si c'est une question fondamentale
parce que nous vivons une pandémie
nous ne vivons pas une épidémie en
france
nous vivons une pandémie à l'échelle
planétaire et j'ai l'impression
j'ai l'impression que nos contemporains
ne rompt pas encore tout à fait réalisé
que nous vivons quelque chose qui touche
la planète entière est la conséquence de
cela c'est qu'il ne servirait
strictement à rien que la france soit
entièrement vacciner dans un état
absolument idéal au milieu d'une europe
qui ne le serait pas et même d'une
europe qui rêveraient d'être vaccinées
ce qu'elle est en train de faire en ce
moment au milieu d'une planète qui ne
l'est pas de telle sorte que je suis en
faveur de la vaccination obligatoire
pour tous à condition que ce soit pour
tous les êtres humains si je puis dire
ce qui est évidemment totalement
utopique
alors de là 2
deux remarques vote par le parlement
bien entendu je souhaiterais qu'il y ait
des discussions au niveau de l'union
européenne je sais très bien que les
questions de santé ne relève pas des
pouvoirs de l'ue eux
néanmoins si une telle décision pouvait
être prise en france
ne serait-il pas possible de poser la
question et qu'il y une recommandation
générale au moins des états disons de
les plus proches de nous france
allemagne espagne italie pour aller du
même pas dans dans ces questions de
l'acsi nation deuxièmement je crois que
ce qui est le plus urgent aujourd'hui
est ce la question de savoir s'il faut
vous rendre le vaccin obligatoire ici ou
s'il faut faire rendre le vaccin
accessible dans l'ensemble de la planète
parce que je suis je ne veux pas jouer
non plus les oiseaux de mauvaise augure
mais on en a pas du tout fini avec cette
pandémie
on parle du variant delta demain on
parlera du val du variant ypsilon qui
peut éclater n'importe où l'idée qu'on
va fermer les frontières est une idée
tout à fait absurde on ne ferme jamais
entièrement les frontières ça n'est pas
possible c'est une pandémie mondiale et
par conséquent je suis aujourd'hui pour
qu'on discute de la possibilité de faire
vacciner le plus vite possible
tous ces noms tous ces pays qui sont
aujourd'hui le brésil l'inde qui sont
dans des états sanitaires bien pires que
les nôtres de telle sorte que le
véritable rapport auquel on doit
réfléchir c'est vaccination obligatoire
dans un seul pays ou dans une seule
région du monde où vaccination possible
le plus vite possible pour l'ensemble de
la planète c'est comme ça à mon avis que
le problème
de la fin de cette pandémie peut se
poser parce que je crois encore une fois
sans jouer les oiseaux de mauvais augure
que tant qu'il y aura des foyers
pandémique ou épidémiques puissants de
cette maladie quelque part dans la
planète
nous ne serons pas protégés c'est
d'ailleurs un des arguments de ceux qui
ne veulent pas se faire vacciner en
disant de toute façon ça ne servirait à
rien et tant est qu'il y aurait toujours
des gens qui ne seraient pas vaccinés et
qui vous qui pourrait y avoir toujours
de nouveaux variants françois
saint-pierre deux minutes avant la pause
oui un non pour dire que de toute façon
ici en france nous sommes dans un état
de droit une démocratie où le
consentement individuelle doit rester
vraiment prioritaire et j'entends bien
votre discours nous avons à faire un
problème de pandémie mondiale
une politique d'incitation forte des
gouvernements naturellement mais il faut
aussi que chaque personne puisse adhérer
et ça ça me semble très important c'est
une confiance c'est une question de
confiance des gens des citoyens dans
l'état je me permets de vous rappeler
que au début de la pandémie en ce mois
de février la ministre madame buses
ministre de la santé expliqué que le
virus n'atteindrait pas la france et
qu'il n'y aurait aucune difficulté
pendant longtemps on a dit que les
masques ça ne servait strictement rien
du tout et la porte parole du
gouvernement disait qu'elle ne savait
même pas comment les mettre
etc etc comment vit-on qu'aujourd'hui
les gens est confiance dans ce
gouvernement dont la parole est très
gravement discrédité
alors la situation est difficile je
pense que le gouvernement a un énorme
effort de conviction a fermé donc de
crédibilité pour que les citoyens des
gens puissent adhérer librement à cette
campagne de vaccination un mot juste je
rebondis sur ce que vous avez dit
françois saint-pierre le problème
effectivement c'est que on sait qu'il
n'ya pas dans tant de soignants que cela
en france qu'on en manque
on en manque notamment dans les ehpad et
est ce qu'on peut imaginer que
de d'empêcher de travailler un certain
nombre d'entre eux surtout dans la
perspective où le variant delta sera
majoritaire est-ce qu'on peut réellement
se passer de ces gens là a priori non
c'est ce que j'évoquais tout à l'heure
est ce qu'une étude d'impact a été fait
est ce qu'elle est en train d'être
réalisées pour mesurer la situation dans
laquelle on se trouverait à ce moment là
je n'ai pas lu quant à moi de d'éléments
significatifs à cet égard mais je ne
suis pas au gouvernement je pas échappé
que c'est pas moi le ministre de la
justice et par conséquent je n'ai pas de
secret d'état vous révéler à cet égard
on fait une pause on reprend notre débat
juste après
[Musique]
merci on a identifié un peu plus de 500
depuis un an et demi
les alertes concernant les menaces de
prédation sur des entreprises françaises
se multiplient en vous avez un pays qui
est affaibli par une crise économique
majeure
ça intéresse les prédateurs parce qu'ils
savent que vous ne pourrez pas vous
défendre
c'est un peu le chacun pour soi dieu
pour tous actuellement dans cette guerre
économique il ya darwinisme classique et
côté économique et les gros mangent les
petits mais là on se trouve devant un
nouveau type de risque le droit est
maintenant utilisée par les états pour
aider leurs entreprises notamment à
affaiblir d'autres entreprises
étrangères
tous les gens qui sont aujourd'hui au
ministère de l'économie ne savent pas ce
que c'est qu'une entreprise puisse y ont
jamais mis les pieds
donc ne leur demandez pas défendre
quelque chose qui ne connaissent pas vu
[Musique]
la grande bretagne a donc eu cinq ans
pour se préparer
cinq ans de psychodrame ça qu'on
négociations politiques
est-ce qu'elle était prête je 31
décembre pour redevenir une île réponse
par du moment où le royaume uni avait
décidé de quitter l'union européenne il
ne pouvait plus continuer de bénéficier
de ses droits équivalents à si vous êtes
dans l'europe pas dans l'europe
vis-à-vis des 27 états autres c'est
juste quelque chose d'inconcevable
l'angleterre vab un perdreau là nos amis
britanniques ont fait un choix en 2016
qui est un choix qui je pense va
impacter l'économie profondément sur les
prochaines années et va impacter des
générations les choses sont en train de
se caler de se mettre en place
est ce que les choses sont totalement
fluide réponse est non
[Musique]
peut-on rendre le vaccin obligatoire
c'est le débat de ce soir avec francis
vol ce qui est philosophe et françois
saint-pierre qui est avocat on se
souvient que au moment où on a commencé
à parler du passé ni terre le
gouvernement à ce moment là ne voulait
surtout pas stigmatiser pour reprendre
le mot qui vous choquer tout à l'heure
francis wolff voulait surtout pas
stigmatiser ceux qui ne voulaient pas se
faire vacciner
donc c'est pour ça qu'on a introduit
dans le passé dit taire ceux qui avaient
fait atteste par exemple ceux qui
avaient eu le coc vide qui était censé
donc être immunisé il ya eu ce souci
pendant un certain temps ne pas
discriminer ceux qui ne voulaient pas se
faire vacciner
c'est vrai qu'à ce moment les imaginait
plus nombreux qu'eux ils ne le saurais
te aujourd'hui enfin c'était quand même
très important ne pas discriminer
francis wolff
oui ne pas discriminer je pense que
c'est très important encore une fois je
ne sais pas en quoi le fait d'être
protégé contre une maladie serait
discriminant mais quels sont les
adversaires de la vaccination alors je
crois qu'on peut distinguer où les
adversaires ou les rétifs disons parce
qu'il ya toute une gradation je pense
qui est extrêmement complexe
on peut distinguer où je crois trois
grands types de population d'abord il ya
des gens qui sont tout à fait éloigné
parce qu'ils jouent pas ils sont bons
car monde ils sont migrants ils n'ont
pas accès à la vaccination ne savent
peut-être même pas que ils pourraient
être vaccinés on voit là ça fait partie
disons du plateau du plafond de verre
des personnes qu'on veut pas le voir ce
qu'ils sont en france bien dans tous
leurs jeux je me place dans le cas de la
france
par conséquent voilà ça c'est une
population difficilement vaccinable
n'est ni pour ni contre l'ignorent il ya
une deuxième
à l'opposé il y à des militants anti
vaccins des militants anti vaccins qui
sont qui ont souvent un discours très
organisé très
qui s'appuie en effet sur des questions
officiellement de liberté individuelle
et qui ont un discours très en apparence
très libertariens c'est à dire y'a rien
au dessus de la liberté individuelle est
en réalité très souvent liés à des
mouvements d'extrême droite
ils ont des motivations diverses saisons
ti vaccins qui sont assez souvent
organes bien organisés ils sont présents
sur les réseaux sociaux etc
il touche une partie de la population
qui est sensible à
c'est ces arguments qui sont d'ailleurs
les gens sont beaucoup moins sensibles à
l'argument de la liberté individuelle
qu'un argument anti système en général
ils veulent encore nous emmerder ils
veulent encore et c'est le isu le ont
collé c'est à dire quelque chose qui est
une rébellion contre toute forme
d'imposition
encore une fois ce n'est pas pour
défendre leurs libertés individuelles
c'est une position de principe contre
quelque chose qui est vague qui est le
système les privilégiés l'élite etc
et puis entre les deux évidemment il y à
toute une partie de la population qui
est rectif qui se demande ce qu'elle est
le véritable risque qui parmi les jeunes
et je voudrais faire ouvrir une
parenthèse le cas disons des jeunes est
particulièrement cruel parce que voici
une population qui en gros a été très
peu touchée par le parent par la
pandémie qui lorsqu'elle a attrapé cette
maladie sont étirées
sans grands effets à court terme moyen
terme ou long terme et qui a le plus
pâti des mesures qui ont été imposées à
tous et je dois dire pour sauver des
gens de ma génération
bon donc je comprends très bien que ces
jeunes qui ont le sentiment qu'on a
sacrifié parfois six mois un an de leur
entrée dans la vie active de leurs
études
eh bien il trouve n'est ce pas que la
coupe est pleine et que on en a marre du
coc vide et on veut vivre
donc ça je comprends très bien cet
argument mais cette partie du de la
population qui à ce type de raisonnement
et particulièrement les jeunes
voilà disons l'ailé et les 18 30 ans à
ceux qui ont à mon avis subit le plus
les effets du du confinement et c est
bien
on peut les convaincre non pas on peut
les convaincre par des arguments
d'empathie par des arguments d'altruisme
par des arguments vous n'allez pas vous
faire vacciner pour votre bien mais pour
ils ont pour les autres pour ne pas
transmettre parce que vous ne
contribuerez pas comme ça à faire
circuler le virus et je crois que ça ça
n'est pas le plus difficile ce qui est
le plus difficile c'est cette partie de
la population qui a priori méfiante et
400 être elle-même complotistes et et
méfiante vis-à-vis de du discours de la
science dunant de vous interrompre mais
parmi les soignants notamment il ya ce
qu'on appelle les sceptiques ils sont
pas du tout anti vaccins mais ils sont
sceptiques à l'égard de ces vaccins la
dot ils pensent à tort ou à raison je me
prononcerai pas qu'ils sont trop récents
qu'on ne sait pas ce que ça va donner
dans l'avenir que ça peut donc laisser
qui peut y avoir des liaisons des
lésions quand ils sont jeunes en plus il
pense que c'est plus risqué par rapport
aux risques que leur fait courir le
coville lui-même et leurs arguments sont
des arguments presque de santé pourra
enfin de leur santé cela ils sont
difficiles
convaincre aussi parce que justement je
crois qu'ils ont ils sont de plus en
plus en baisse pour une raison très
simple c'est que on a de plus en plus
heures de recul à la fois sur ce que
c'est que la rn messager et sur
l'efficacité du vaccin lui-même
l'absence jusqu'à preuve du contraire
dans les quelques millions de personnes
qui ont été vaccinées par ce type de
vaccin je ne pense pas que ce soit les
les cas les plus difficiles je crois que
les cas les plus difficiles
et de ce point de vue là je suis
d'accord avec françois sa pire c'est
quand même ces gens qui se méfient des
discours ambiants général
il est vrai que ce gouvernement comme à
peu près tous les autres gouvernements
démocratiques ont changé de discours en
permanence sur les masques sur les tests
sur les vaccins etc
au début la france est partie très en
retard sur les vaccins tellement elle
avait peur des anti vaccins souvenons
nous bon alors après on a rattrapé puis
maintenant on voit que les anti vaccins
c'est en grande partie justement un
effet de 7,2 de cette ignorance qui est
en train de descendre mais je crois ou
juste le point où je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec mon interlocuteur c'est
sur le fait qu'il faudrait tenter de
faire comprendre les choses avec des
arguments dans lesquels la part égale
serait fait l égoïsme et à l'altruisme
si je puis dire c'est à dire c'est votre
intérêt et surtout c'est l'intérêt de
votre entourage c'est l'entourent lente
l'intérêt de tous ceux que vous aimez de
ne pas transmettre quelque chose de
nuisibles et évidemment cela exige des
campagnes et il est où je comprends
qu'il soit très difficile pour le
gouvernement de mener des campagnes
alors que bon mais c'est quand même à ma
banque que ça fait quand même un moment
que ça dure mais c'est ce que je pense
pas qu'une campagne changera quoi que
non mais il peut y avoir des deux
nouveaux porte parole des influenceurs
qu'ils peuvent
et je voudrais juste concernant égoïsme
altruisme dire un mot de la position de
la cgt qui m'a beaucoup choqué
pourquoi cette position de la cgt en
particulier m'a choqué parce que en
effet pour moi la cgt était quand même
liée à toute une histoire du mouvement
social a toute une histoire du mouvement
ouvrier qui a été à l'avant-garde pour
les vaccinations pour les moyens
anticonceptionnels pour toutes les
nouveautés musicales qui ont sauvé la
vie de d'énormément de d'enfants en bas
âge de femmes dans la détresse
il ya eu tout cela dans l'histoire du
mouvement ouvrier que représenta cgt
parce qu'elle représentait quelque chose
du point de vue de la solidarité de
classe et qu'aujourd'hui il n'y a ni
plus dans le discours d'un syndicat
tient à cette histoire que l'histoire de
honda pas stigmatiser nos mandants m'a
beaucoup fait de peine pour l'histoire
de la cgt françois saint pierre la
méfiance de la population des gens de
nous tous en vain ce gouvernement est
quand même un niveau très élevé et cela
s'est vu notamment sur les outils
numériques de lutte contre la pandémie
alors fallait que tu as dis vous évoquez
à l'instant là le pass sanitaire qui a
été contesté en justice
là le past and terre c'est une question
réglementaire qui relève de la
compétence du gouvernement et des
personnes
une association ont saisi le conseil
d'état de la question de savoir si c'est
tout il a était attentatoire à la vie
privée des uns et des autres et alors ça
tombe bien parce que c'est avant-hier
seulement que le conseil d'état a rendu
sa décision et il a jugé que non ce pass
sanitaire était un outil numérique utile
qui était respectueux de la vie privée
des gens dans la mesure où il ne
transmettait pas d'information
particulière autre que sur le vaccin
donc on verra maintenant qu'est-ce usage
quel usage par don sera fait de ce pass
sanitaire parce que j'ai eu à midi au
déjeuner j'étais dans un restaurant
tranquille j'ai pas eu à montrer mon
pass sanitaire moi j'ai un code qr bon
voilà
donc quelle est l'utilité de ce pass
sanitaire ultérieurement pour les
restaurants les cinémas pour prendre
l'avion pour aller en corse on voit que
ça peut être sur différents usages pour
l'heure très peu de choses vous allez en
italie sans aucun contrôle par exemple
bon donc la question est de savoir si à
l'avenir dans un proche avenir dans les
semaines qui viennent se passe sanitaire
sera utilisé comme un badge pour entrer
dans différents lieux de la vie courante
quotidienne et là on pourra se reposer
la question de la discrimination
je suis bien d'accord qu'il faut
toujours peser l'intérêt général que
vous évoquiez et puis les options
individuelle et personnelle de chacun
mais nous avons un fort taux de
réticence des gens dans ces outils
numériques
parce que l'on craint une surveillance
massive
aujourd'hui même les caisses
d'assurance-maladie honte accepté de
transmettre et je lu dans la presse un
haut médecins leurs données sur les
personnes qui sont vaccinées
donc nous voyons bien que le débat
progresse et en un sens c'est
parfaitement légitime nous voyons cela
mais quel usage en sera-t-il fait plus
tard
là encore je pense qu'il faut être très
à l'écouté de l'opinion du consentement
des gens je me souviens encore de de
l'échec patent de la première
application ce top cow vide au bout de
plusieurs mois d'essais y avait
peut-être 2% de la population qui a été
téléchargé l'application le premier
ministre jean castex et son ministre de
la justice comment s'appelle t déjà j'ai
oublié ont avoué qu'ils n'avaient pas
téléchargé eux-mêmes l'application bon
tout ça est resté vraiment très très
superficielle la nouvelle application
tout senti qu vide est elle beaucoup
plus téléchargées on a peu de données là
dessus et c'est significatif qu'à mon
sens cette toujours et encore un échec
nous avons en revanche l'usagé de ces
codes qr qui je le disais à l'instant me
semble
beaucoup moins invasives dans la vie
privée des gens à leur façon de vivre
françois saint pierre la question va se
poser de vacciner enfin de rendre
obligatoire le vaccin pour la totalité
de la population il est déjà en
filigrane une fois qu'on ne leur a rendu
obligatoire pour les soignants on parle
aussi de le rendre obligatoire pour tous
les employés qui sont en contact avec le
public
dans un souci d'égalité d'ailleurs tout
simplement mais la question se posera
aussi pour le reste de la population je
disais tout à l'heure au départ on ne
voulait surtout pas stigmatiser ceux qui
voulaient pas se faire vacciner
on peut imaginer qu'on va commencer à
les stigmatiser
justement avec des outils comme le pet
sanitaires si demain il le paie
sanitaire c'est uniquement ceux qui ont
été vaccinés c'est à dire que les tests
pcr devienne payant donc cher le pc
dieter sion il devient obligatoire pour
aller pour prendre les transports en
commun pour aller au théâtre pour elle
aussi débat pour aller au restaurant
pour aller au bar ça voudra dire qu'on
admet tous autant que nous sommes que
ceux qui ne sont pas vaccinés n'ont plus
le droit d'aller dans ces endroits là
peut-être même un jour les chefs
de chez eux comme on a parfois chasser
les soignants pendant le premier
confinement qui menaçait pour c'est
certain l'immeuble dans lequel ils
vivaient de dire amener le coc vide
on se souvient des mots que retrouver
certains soignants sur leur voiture
aller habiter ailleurs peut-être qu'on
va faire la même chose demain pour ceux
qui ne sont pas vaccinés oui mais on a
stigmatisé ans et si je puis dire on a
chassé des immeubles aussi des
restaurateurs chinois ou des gens qui
avaient la peau jaune tout à fait au
début de l'épidémie puisque c'était le
virus chinois lors c'est serré action
particulièrement odieuse d'une partie de
la population ne doivent pas je crois
déterminer les meilleures solutions
éthique ou politique née roth vous savez
bien que à un moment est-ce que vous est
ce que ça vous dérangera avoue francis
wolff si tout à coup ce qui ne sont pas
vaccinés ne peuvent plus aller ni au
restaurant ni eau ni dans les bars new
théâtre ni au cinéma ni l'ubs a alors ce
qui me dérange en effet là dedans c'est
l'idée que toute mesure qu'elle dans
quelque sens qu'elle aille accroît les
inégalités
je veux dire vous faites vous rendez le
vaccin obligatoire vous allait accroître
les inégalités de ceux qui ne voudront
pas parce qu'ils n'auront pas de stars
vous ne rendez pas obligatoire eh bien
vous accroissez les inégalités parce que
quels sont ceux qui en pâtissent le plus
eh bien on le sait aujourd'hui ce sont
les populations les plus à risque ce
sont les populations les plus éloignés
de la vaccination
donc je veux dire lol on est tout à fait
piégé parce que de toute façon quelle
que soit la mesure que l'on prend ou que
l'on ne croit que l'on ne prend pas on
accroît les inégalités de l'accès aux
soins et de l'accès est là encore une
fois à la vaccination
parce que bien entendu on sait qu'une
grande partie
là une grande partie de la population
était aujourd'hui vacciner et peut-être
je ne parle pas des personnes du
troisième ou du quatrième âge est sans
doute celle qui est le moins susceptible
d'attraper aujourd'hui la maladie et que
la maladie touche beaucoup plus les gens
qui sont qui vivent dans de mauvaises
conditions sanitaires dans les banlieues
etc
donc c'est extrêmement compliqué parce
que de toute façon
à supposer un gouvernement idéal ce que
une plage au nord je n'en connais pas la
décision de toute façon est piégé
françois saint pierre alors j'ajoute à
la complexité du débat en disant que la
crainte des dd deschamps envers les
outils numériques de lutte contre la
pandémie me sens parfaitement légitime
cette l'association la cadrature du net
dont vous avez entendu parler qui à mon
avis réalise un travail absolument
remarquable et a vraiment développé un
thème d' alerte sur le fait que par
exemple l'application tous sentis coheed
n'est que le prélude à une surveillance
beaucoup plus pérenne et invasive de
l'état sur l'attitude des gens la
difficulté de l' usage de ces outils
numériques
c'est que passée la pandémie passer la
crise sanitaire
ces outils subsisteront nous avons eu le
même débat récemment sur l' usage des
drones policiers nous avons une
extension des moyens de surveillance des
citoyens par l'état sous le prétexte
parfaitement légitime de la pandémie qui
sera par la suite utilisée de manière
beaucoup plus ample donc je pense aussi
que la réticence des uns et des autres
face à cette politique sanitaire
s'explique par une crainte de voir
l'état les surveiller de façon beaucoup
plus intrusive voire totalitaire à un
moment donné
lorsque la justification initiale sera
dépassé c'est extrêmement compliqué moi
je pense que ce qui est très il n'y a
pas de juste mesure je pense ça n'existe
pas il n'y a pas de bonne solution pas
plus qu'il n'ya de gouvernement idéal et
par conséquent ce qui est extrêmement
important c'est que les uns et les
autres puissent ils peuvent alors leur
point de vue qu'il y est une instance de
débat que ce le ce débat soit bien
dialectique
à chacun ses responsabilités le
gouvernement va impulser une politique
va prendre des décrets qui pourront être
contestés devant le conseil d'état va
faire voter des lois qui pourront être
contestés devant le conseil
constitutionnel
et lorsque des procès seront instruits
contre des personnes celles ci pourront
exercer différents recours pour faire
valoir leurs droits et je crois que
c'est comme ça que cet arbitrage qui est
évolutif entre les nécessité pour le
gouvernement de dudu lutte contre la
pandémie donc d'une politique sanitaire
et bien et les libertés individuelles et
la vie privée cela s'arbitrent est ce
assez évolué dans le temps
je rappelais le gouvernement qui disait
que le la pandémie ne viendrait pas en
france que le masque ça ne servait à
rien du tout je dis aujourd'hui que
certains outils numériques sanitaires
peuvent s'avérer franchement extrêmement
préoccupant par la suite s'ils sont
maintenus donc je crois que l'esprit de
résistance des gens face à cette
politique sanitaire n'est pas seulement
un effet de complotisme ou quant à soi
bien gaulois comme avait dit de manière
bien filmé le président macron il ya
quelques mois n'est ce pas cette aussi
un souci bien compréhensible de ce que
l'état mène des politiques nécessaires
mais pas plus et ça c'est un dialogue
constant entre le gouvernement l'état et
les citoyens c'est ça une démocratie
dans cette voie je ne suis en partie
d'accord avec cela parce que
le gars l'état en l'occurrence il ya le
gouvernement qui prend des
responsabilités au nom de l'état il ya
les citoyens il ya quelque chose d'autre
qui est
la société la société qui n'est pas
l'état qui n'est pas non plus les
citoyens individuels
je veux dire par là je veux le dire
aussi bien positivement que négativement
peut-être qu'on pourrait faire de
mauvais usage de tous sentis covin mais
vous ne croyez pas qu'à chaque fois que
je fais des recherches sur google je
suis infiniment plus espionner que par
le gouvernement ou par je ne sais quel
fantasme de gouvernements totalitaires
que nous aurions je pense que on est
infiniment mieux protéger des incursions
de l'état dans notre vie privée que des
incursions des sociétés comme les gaffes
acquis à chaque fois que je fais des
recherches on sait exactement tous
pratiquement tout de ma vie privée de
mes goûts de mes 2 mai appétence de ce
que j'ai fait de ce que j'ai envie de
faire et c est je trouve que ça c'est
une véritable inquiétude est que les
gens sont beaucoup plus méfiants de
l'état du système etc qui en
l'occurrence qui en l'occurrence et spa
essaye je ne parle pas de ce
gouvernement mais tous les gouvernements
démocratiques et c'est de naviguer à vue
en fonction des nécessités de la société
car c'est la seule chose qui était dans
son ensemble qui est touché par cette
pandémie et d'une façon je le répète
encore une fois d'une façon qui est
inégale selon les cas selon là selon la
le candidat de l'intégration sociale des
uns ou des autres
néanmoins l'état des moyens de
coercition à votre rencontre et à mon
encontre l'encontre de tous les citoyens
dont ne disposent pas facebook google
croyez-vous ou amazon
croyez vous que
que c'est que ces grandes sociétés ne
dispose pas aussi de moyens qui ne sont
pas évidemment les lieux mêmes types de
de coercition mais qu'ils ont des moyens
de déterminer ma conduite ou de la
prévoir de l'anticiper ou de la
déterminer voilà par des d'autres moyens
je suis d'accord en revanche en revanche
puisque ce que vous entendez par à la
coercition c'est la menace de sanctions
je suis bien d'accord que ne faut pas
demain menacer les gens qui ne se ferait
pas vacciner de sanctions qui seraient
immédiatement en considéré comme
empiétant sur libertés individuelles il
ya une gradation possible il peut y
avoir des avertissements il peut y avoir
il peut y avoir des menaces d'amande on
voit on a bien vu comment ça s'est passé
pour le port du masque où il y avait une
voix la grande tolérance donc bien
entendu il faut texte extrêmement
méfiant vis-à-vis des incursions de 2,2
de l'état qui menace toujours qui
pourrait toujours devenir du jour au
lendemain totalitaire il est nécessaire
d'être démocratique je crois que nous le
sommes à ces prévenus contre cette
menace plus que nous ne sommes contre
d'autres d'animaux françois saint-pierre
écoutez bien sûr que les gaffes à
facebook ou twitter peuvent présenter
des risques importants pour le respect
nos vies privées et les diffamations qui
peuvent nous cibler je voudrais vous
dire à titre d'exemple que le combat est
le même contre les intrusions de l'état
ou les intrusions des gaffes à hier le
tribunal de paris a condamné twitter
pour ne pas avoir pris de mesures
suffisamment énergique contre les propos
racistes ou stigmatisants qui circulent
sur ce réseau social
et c'est une grande première que l'on
doit aux avocats notamment à mon
confrère alain jacubowicz qui a mené ce
combat et au juge qui l'a sont de
véritables garants des libertés c'est la
raison pour laquelle je pense vraiment à
chacun ses responsabilités
le gouvernement mène une politique
sanitaire
nous les avocats et les tribunaux nous
sommes là aussi pour penser à la
protection des droits des gens des
citoyens pour que la liberté soit
sauvegardée dans ce grand tumulte
sanitaire mais à vous entendre françois
saint-pierre et d'après ce que vous
venez de dire sur les outils
informatiques
ça doit vous rendre extrêmement méfiant
vis-à-vis du pass sanitaire lui même et
donc c'est une manière d'encourager ceux
qui ne veulent pas se faire vacciner à
ne pas star ac' signer parce qu'après
tout ils ont peut-être exactement les
mêmes soucis et c'est au nom de de leur
liberté de leur méfiance envers les
outils que qu'il refuse d'avoir le qr
code dont vous êtes si fier fort
j'espère ne pas avoir diffusé une
mauvaise parole
je pense que nous vivons une société
extrêmement moderne et ses outils
numériques son nouveau récents on n'en
mesure pas totalement l'efficacité et
les dangers moi je suis tout comme vous
parfaitement connecté j'utilise à fond
google et toute la possibilité à
capacité de documentation d'information
sur internet et communication aussi ça
ne m'empêche pas d'être parfaitement
conscient d'être l'un parmi tant
d'autres à être observées par cette
grande machine qui est en même temps
effrayante
c'est notre modernité on lui échappe pas
je remercie tous les deux d'avoir
participé à ce débat merci de nous avoir
suivis et rendez vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]
oui